Bradley Cooper maybe one of the hottest
stars in Hollywood today but in a new
interview with W Magazine the a-list
actor says he didn't have the same
reputation at the start of his career
quote I've always been an underdog
I was always operating under the lens of
not really being seen as the main guy
Cooper added I've heard it all my career
early on I didn't get a role because
they said I wasn't
ouch and despite some of the
discouraging feedback he received the
award-winning actor says quote in the
end you have to reserve your attention
for the work and not listen to anyone
but this isn't the first time the 43
year old has told this story in 2015
Cooper recalls his early Hollywood years
during a sit-down with Barbara Walters
so how do you go from being unwell to
being the sexiest man alive tell me I
have no idea obviously there's something
afoot what indeed
et recently caught up with Cooper and
Lady gaga
his co-star in a star is born almost
every single person has told me they
liked the way I sounded but that they
didn't like the way I look I think
you're beautiful a film that he not only
stars in but also helped write produce
and direct what are some of the things
that you guys have been told that you
had to change in order this interview
would be about 15 minutes yeah yeah this
is it's a rough business it's a very
hard business and you have to have thick
skin it's definitely not for everybody
and I've heard everything everything
every face everything in my body yeah I
was suggested that to get a nose job
before I put up my first single and
taught the video and I just said no the
chemistry between you when did you know
that you had this chemistry was an
instant was it something a trust that
you had to build over time the chemistry
was instant the minute that she was kind
of to let me come and talk to her about
this potential project so the fact that
we forged a friendship by creating art
together
is kind of the most idyllic way to to to
use that chemistry and this has to just
be the start this has to be number one
and there has to be 10 more lady gaga
Bradley Cooper films in my life would be
a blessing that they take us like 88
goes yeah
[Music]